gabi may may I ask who you are wearing
literally I am literally wearing my
husband I love it yes my young husband
you look so handsome
he's so cure right I will say the DMX
challenge is happening right now you're
prepared if he returns the favor and
wears you all over his clothes I believe
as per our prenup he actually has to
once a year you have to Drake yourself
and the other person's face technicality
but if you don't the kicker doesn't come
in so it's the rearward supercommittee
you know one of the things I love about
AGT and especially this season is that
it is probably one the most inclusive
shows on television one of those talent
groups that have been under fire this
week or at least a lot of people jump me
to the defense is young boys who want to
dance after Laura Spencer's comments
what did you make of that I I think
people make a lot of unfortunate and
uninformed comments that if that
actually have real effects on you know
all kinds of people worldwide you know
one of my closest friends is Dule Hill
you know he literally started dance at a
very young age and he said it best you
know I mean like we need to encourage
all of our children to do whatever it is
that they want to do and if that's dance
we we all need to be giving them all
standing ovations and yelling Bravo
Bravo because you're only going to
create better more amazing more
compassionate children you know the the
more we encourage all of our kids and
quickly it is the 25th anniversary of
Friends of course you were in an episode
Ross this is Joey Joey Ross Hey hi it's
nice to meet you yeah I used to have a
friend named Joey
I don't anymore what do you remember
most about that experience I remember
that this show I was on that I loved
City of Angels a black medical show I
joined that season and we got canceled
on like Monday and they're like you want
to do friends oh my god I don't watch it
is it good is it like who's on it okay
yeah cool and so Tuesday I got a
different job and it was just like wow
I'm gonna have a check this week so
that's kind of my take away from friends
cuz I wasn't like a huge like friends
who were I had no clue about it either
story lives I had no idea about anything
it wasn't until afterwards if you were
like you know you're the first black
where's my friends and then someone
somewhere at the network was like no we
counted and you're actually the the
first african-american love interest on
friends but aren't you glad you cannot
broke ground there
[Music]